NARRATOR:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
New York Giants co-owner
and prolific film producer
Steve Tisch joins the tank,
where things
get even more heated...
Let me finish
talking, Mark.
shut up, Kevin.
...In one of the season's
biggest bidding wars.
You have three offers
on the table.
Hold on.
I'm gonna offer $250,000.
I will offer you $350,000.
Are you done playing games
with these guys?
Do not give up
your equity.
I'm gonna offer you
$1 million.
whoa!
NARRATOR: In the tank,
hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
It's a hobby that should be
taken behind the barn and shot.
Do you realize how bad
you just screwed up?
what did I say?
NARRATOR: If the sharks hear
a great idea...
Sales to date
are $4.2 million.
oh.
This is a megawatt hero.
NARRATOR: ...They're ready to
invest using their own money.
It's a sweet deal.
And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You know
we're the right partners.
So you just threw Steve
under a bus.
Yeah. Lori just
kicked me to the curb.
Yes!
maybe she's not
the right partner at all.
Stop.
we were just about to close.
No, you weren't.
JOHN: No, you weren't.
Sit down, Lori.
NARRATOR:
who are the sharks?
They're millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin o'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Mark Cuban -- notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas mavericks.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
over 300 products
grossing over $500 million
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion
and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
And Steve Tisch.
He is a renowned film producer,
businessman,
and co-owner
of the New York Giants.
He is also the only person with
an Oscar and a Super Bowl ring.
First into the tank
is a couple with a product
hoping to emulate the best part
of a favorite breakfast food.
[ laughs ]
Hi.
my name is Chris Pouy.
And I am
Tiffany Panhilason.
And our company is called
Cow Wow cereal milk.
And we're asking
for $250,000
in return for 10%
of that company.
You know after you have
your favorite bowl of cereal
and you drink the leftover milk
and it tastes like...
Heaven?
heaven?
That's cereal milk,
and we've bottled it
and made it good for you.
So, how do we get kids
to try Cow Wow?
We tell them a story.
Once upon a time,
there was a dairy farm
that ran out of hay.
So the farmers ran
straight to the cupboards
and fed their cows the only
thing they had left -- cereal.
The next morning,
when they milked their cows,
the milk tasted sweet,
just like the cereals
they love to eat.
The end.
the end.
Without any further ado,
Tiffany's gonna
hand out some samples,
and I'm gonna get out
of this ridiculous cow costume.
Thank you, Tiffany.
Thank you.
thank you.
All right, so, what Tiffany
is handing out to you guys
are fruity Trudy
and chocolate chip Cathy.
And that sugar label's
actually wrong.
We made a mistake in production.
it's only 20 grams of sugar.
14 grams of sugar are actually
in a serving of milk.
A lot of people
don't know that.
You're basically
selling milk to kids that tastes
like the leftover milk
in the bottom of a cereal bowl.
Yes, sir.
What made you think
of this?
Like, are you
major cereal lovers?
Milk lovers? Like...?
Yes and yes and yes.
We were, like, in one of those
yogurt places one night.
And there were so many
flavors. There was like
20 flavors of yogurt.
And then we were
in the convenience store,
and I look,
and I'm just like, "wow.
"why does milk
only have three flavors --
chocolate, vanilla,
and strawberry?" like...
The milk in the bottom
of the bowl --
is that something
people like?
I actually --
I'm a cereal-for-dinner guy.
I love the taste of cereal milk
in the bottom of the bowl.
Yeah, there's no question,
right?
Everybody loves -- like you
said, everybody loves it.
Yeah, I mean, it's the
best part of the bowl.
it's the best part
of the bowl.
I always looked at it like it
had backwash and drool in it.
Why would I want it?
Have you tested this
with kids?
What kind of feedback
have you gotten with kids?
Absolutely.
they love it.
There's not a kid that has said
that they didn't.
Let me ask you something.
I'm dairy-intolerant.
So I didn't try it.
but, Steve, you --
how -- how did it taste?
you didn't like it.
Yeah, I mean, look, I'm gonna
give you a "b" on the taste.
It's not got enough
cereal taste.
It's not quite
sweet enough.
It doesn't remind me
of my favorite cereals.
Okay.
what are your sales?
It's $20,000.
we just launched with one sku.
Have you had any reorders
on it?
Yes, we've had reorders
in all of our grocery stores
that we were in.
And how many are they?
Right now
it's eight Bristol farms,
three test stores
for albertsons,
and we actually
are one step away
from getting
a confirmed deal
from one of the largest grocers
in the country.
And how big
would that deal be?
About $100,000.
Which category are you trying
to garner share in?
Because this is not
a refrigerated product.
Flavored milk --
$1.5-billion industry.
It doesn't need
to be refrigerated,
but it tastes better
when it's cold.
Is it refrigerated
or not?
It is in albertsons
and Bristol farms,
but it doesn't
need to be.
that is a whole
different story.
Getting shelf space
in refrigerated area
is extremely expensive
no matter
how your cow suit looks.
CUBAN: Now all of a sudden,
you're competing with Borden,
who has flavored milk and
can easily come out with more.
So you're competing with them
and all their marketing dollars.
And I think that's an uphill
battle that is insurmountable.
$250,000 isn't even gonna
get you into the game
to compete
against those guys
'cause you don't have
a pure differentiation.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
But, guys, you know,
this one packet right here
has 24 grams of sugar.
20. That's wrong.
it has 170 --
20 or 24.
170 calories
is a lot...
It's 170 calories.
...For this
little carton.
it's a lot, yeah.
To be selling this
to kids.
and a lot
of sugar isn't...
I mean, there's an obesity issue
we already have.
That's a lot of calories
for a kid.
We have less sugar
than any other flavored
milk on the market.
It's less sugar than any juice
or any soda.
When they made a petition
to take flavored milk
out of schools,
there was an incredible backlash
from the kids.
You know,
there was one kid in Ohio
that wrote like
a five-paragraph essay
about how they wanted
to get milk back in the school.
Do you realize how bad
you just screwed up?
What did I say?
look, you just
came in here.
We probably
never would have known
that they tried to take
flavored milk out of any school.
And you just told us
one of the biggest red flags
that we probably
could have uncovered.
Well, the reason
I want to tell you is because
when they took flavored milk
out of schools,
the kids started drinking
soda and juice.
And they demanded,
"please, give us back
our -- our chocolate milk,"
because they loved it,
it's more nutritious.
It has nine essential vitamins
and nutrients.
The ratio of carbs to protein --
flavored milk is being marketed
as the perfect recovery drink
for athletes.
Say that again.
What?!
Chocolate milk -- "got milk?"
did a $25-million campaign
marketing chocolate milk
to athletes
because the ratio of carbs
to protein
is actually better
than most --
not in my locker room.
is it in your locker room?
[ laughs ] No.
but this product is not
positioned to athletes.
This is for children.
POUY: Well, I'm just saying
pediatricians and health --
so people are gonna start
dumping yoo-hoo on people
after they win
the championship?
[ laughter ]
I think it's dangerous
to give kids this product.
I-i don't see any value in it
for me. I'm out.
POUY: We're not trying
to get kids
to drink something
that's unhealthy.
There's no ceragenin.
there's no artificial flavors.
There's no
artificial sweeteners.
We have the cleanest label
in flavored milk.
You guys,
I don't even like milk.
So, I have to love
and feel passionate
about any deal that I do.
So I'm out.
Chris,
I love the concept.
I love cereal milk.
I love the branding.
As I said earlier, it's not
quite there in terms of taste.
It's a "b."
I need it to be an "a."
I don't think your product
is there yet.
I'm out.
In the end,
what happens?
All cows come back
to the pasture right here.
Right.
all right?
So you're saying you want
your udder pulled?
No, no, I'm basically saying --
I'm basically saying
it's a very old
and established space --
a $1.5-billion
flavored-milk market.
I would think to get a valuation
here of $2.5 million,
you would need a much more
concise business plan
that can explain
to any one of us
why you have a hope in hell
of getting share.
'cause I think right now
we're going to get crushed
like an udder.
I'm very out.
Thank you, guys.
appreciate it.
thank you.
GREINER: Good luck.
PANHILASON: I think the sharks
gave great advice.
I mean, they are successful
for a reason.
POUY: But I think maybe
they're just a little too old
and they just don't get it.
It doesn't mean that
we're gonna stop from here.
yeah.
We're just gonna take
their advice and make our...
Keep on moo-ving.
Yes. [ chuckles ]
make our brand better.
[ bicycle bell rings,
child laughs ]
I'm Joan.
and I'm Julia.
BOTH: And we're sisters
from Normal, Illinois.
Growing up in a family of seven,
everything was homemade.
Baking is practically
in our blood.
We've been baking since we've
been little girls with our mom
in the kitchen
and haven't stopped.
Let's go eat.
We've developed
the perfect alternative
to one of America's
guiltiest pleasures.
It's gourmet,
it's delicious,
and there's nothing like it
on the market.
[ both laugh ]
Working together as sisters
is fun.
I'm the boss.
no, you're not.
yeah, I am.
Neither of us are the boss.
we're partners.
We are partners, but most
of the time, I am the boss.
Okay. A little room.
Our facility is
the world's tiniest kitchen.
Getting an investment
would put us into a place
where we can actually have
a production.
Americans are gonna love our
product because it's unique
and it's a sweet treat
that everyone can enjoy.
We want to be
in mass production,
and we want to become
a national brand,
and we need the sharks
to help us do that.
Hi. I'm Joan Pacetti.
And I'm Julia Schmid.
and we're sisters.
And together
we own...
BOTH:
...The Cookie Dough Cafe.
We are seeking $50,000
for 20% of our company.
Anyone who has ever baked
homemade cookies
knows how tempting
the cookie dough can be.
It's gooey. It's sweet.
it's sinful.
But we all know we should not be
sneaking bites of cookie dough.
We've heard about raw eggs
and salmonella,
and every pre-packaged
cookie dough has labels
saying, "warning --
do not eat raw."
even though we know this,
we still swipe by the spoonful.
That's why we created
a safe, edible cookie dough
that is strictly made for
eating, indulging, and enjoying.
Yes!
Don't bother
preheating your oven.
You can enjoy our product
straight from the jar.
SCHMID:
this is the real deal.
This is your mama's
cookie dough.
It's creamy,
loaded full
of chocolate chips,
delicious candies, real butter,
and no added preservatives.
We have the only gourmet, edible
cookie dough on the market
specifically made
to consume as is.
We have hand-packed thousands
of pints of cookie dough
in the world's
tiniest kitchen.
We need your help.
So grab a spoon
and dig right in.
Yes!
hey! [ laughs ]
you get the Oreo,
Steve.
And Lori gets
the chocolate chip.
Whoa!
Now, what is stopping salmonella
from growing in this?
It contains no eggs
whatsoever.
Hmm.
GREINER:
oh, this is great.
thank you.
This tastes so good.
what does this pint sell for?
$6.99 is what
it retails for.
And what do you
make it for?
$2.20.
Can you also bake cookies
with this, or no?
BOTH: You can.
But they'll just be
really flat because
there's no baking soda.
And they don't taste as good
baked without the eggs.
And you've been in business
how long?
A little over a year.
How are the sales?
Our sales to date
are $24,000.
What were your sales
last month?
Last month, they were
probably $1,600.
1,600 units or $1,600?
Dollars.
Yes.
$1,600?
we were
in seven stores.
Seven stores.
we just --
we got a purchase order
last week
for more than what
we've sold all year.
It's gonna put us
in an additional
50 fresh market
grocery stores.
Your purchase order was for how
much money and how many units?
2,300 pints. And we'll make
about $6,000 on it.
GREINER: What's your mode
of selling?
How are you trying to get
your product out there?
We don't do any marketing
or anything like that. Um --
how are you getting into
the grocery stores, though?
'cause that's very hard.
we approached
the fresh market.
Yeah, we went and talked to
the manager in normal, Illinois.
He looked at our packaging.
he tasted our product.
And he was like,
"this is gonna be huge."
and how much has he sold --
has that one store sold?
$11,000 of our sales
last year.
Over a year?
in just one store.
Do you really think,
in one store,
a product that only does $11,000
can stay on the shelf?
It's $900 a month.
Who cares?
Now, stop it.
But, I mean,
think about it.
If you could get
that year back
and you never had
this nightmare, would you --
shut up, Kevin.
Kevin!
Are you kidding?
How much
have you invested?
$35,000 total.
total.
What are you gonna do
with the $50,000?
Purchase equipment that'll help
automate the packing process
'cause that's the most
time-consuming part
of our job
right now.
What are you guys doing now
to make a living?
Is this all you're doing?
I'm an agent at
an R.V. Dealership.
okay.
And I'm
a stay-at-home mom.
We come from a family
of entrepreneurs.
Our dad literally swept
the floor in a factory
and started
his own business.
Unfortunately,
he's passed away,
but one of our older brothers
took over the business,
and it's a multimillion-dollar
business now.
How come your brother hasn't
helped you with the $50,000?
We haven't asked.
Why?
I don't know.
Sense of pride? I mean...
[ chuckles ] yeah.
I get that.
We're here, obviously,
for the $50,000,
but we also need
some connections,
like getting our product
in a manufacturing facility.
We don't know
how to do that.
JOHN: That leads me
to my next statement.
I love it.
If you do this deal,
I'm gonna add egg to yours.
But it's so early
at this point.
I would have to do
way more work.
I would have to ask you
for so much of the company
that it would be unfair.
I wouldn't have the time
to help you.
I'm a customer
but not an investor.
I'm out.
I like what you guys are doing.
it tastes great.
But to Daymond's point,
you're still in that early,
early, early stage,
and you're gonna
be turning to us
because you don't want to
have to go through this blindly.
That's the whole point
of coming here, right?
And so that creates
a lot of work for us.
But don't you think
that's good, too?
We don't have
$1 million in sales
and we're not in here
asking you for $500,000?
Can't you see this
in stadiums...
oh, absolutely.
...And theaters and
single cookie-dough cups?
Yeah, in some respects,
you're right.
But it's too early.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
O'LEARY: My big problem with
this is the proof of concept.
You've practically
sold nothing.
I don't think this is
going to be a big product.
I really don't.
When we just got
50 additional stores?
You would give up
when you just went
from 7 stores to 50
in a week?
I mean, look, I don't want
to insult you --
Kevin sees the word "dough,"
and he gets confused.
I don't want you to pursue
the path to hell on Earth.
It's a hobby that eventually
should be taken behind the barn
and shot.
I hate it.
I'm out.
NARRATOR:
three sharks are out.
Julia and Joan have only two
chances left to make a deal.
We've had people approach us,
and we can't get
to that next step because
we weren't with a distributor.
We've had Walgreens
call us up.
We had everything finalized
to be in their flagship stores
like you have in Hollywood,
downtown Chicago.
How did you
get into Walgreens?
They
approached us.
They saw
our product...
where?
...On the fresh market shelf
and called us up.
Because we weren't with
a distributor they used --
you know,
we're not big enough yet,
they said,
"call us when you get in."
so that door is still open,
you think?
Oh, yeah.
it's still -- I talked
to her two weeks ago.
You know, I remember what
it was like to be just like you.
I don't agree with Mark.
I don't mind doing hard work.
And you don't mind
doing hard work.
no, I don't.
So I think
we'll put our heads together,
do a lot of hard work,
and get it out there everywhere.
But I also was sitting here
thinking, when you said,
"it would be good in stadiums."
I've got a guy next to me.
he's got some stadiums, himself.
I think it's a great product
for stadiums.
I've also got great contacts
in hotels.
I think this in a hotel room --
slam dunk.
Would you want
to partner with me?
Go 50/50?
Yes, and you get two sharks
with different contacts,
different connections,
different opportunities.
We like that.
We like that. Yeah.
GREINER: It's a lot.
How about we give you $100,000
for a 30% stake?
I think we should offer $100,000
for 40%.
Okay.
And we see this also paired
with a large ice cream --
guys, guys!
that is a sweet deal.
What are you gonna do?
did you hear
what they said?
It's a lot of dough
for your dough.
I would rather do
the $50,000.
I would rather do $50,000
for 20%.
We don't want to give up much
more than 20% of our company.
Joan, I'm gonna give you
some rolling papers so
you can smoke this stuff.
[ laughs ]
You should take that offer.
are you out of your mind?
40% of our company?
Oh, my God.
GREINER: How about this?
We'll go back
to $100,000 at 30%.
Steve,
are you okay with that?
I'm okay with that.
Girls,
do you accept our offer?
We'll do it.
yes.
Done?
it's a deal.
Yes, it's done.
TISCH:
thank you, ladies.
Yay!
GREINER: Yay!
Good job, girls.
ladies.
Thank you!
thank you!
Thank you so much.
TISCH: Thanks, guys.
[ both laugh ]
Yeah, the rookie
closes his first deal.
congratulations, rook.
[ laughs ]
We are so excited and happy
we got a deal.
We feel like it'll build
our brand 10 times faster
than we could have done
on our own.
Yeah.
100 times faster. Yeah.
yeah.
NARRATOR:
Last season, Tania Patruno,
along with company spokesman
NFL running back Brandon Jacobs,
struck a deal with Daymond John
for their protein-infused water
PRO-NRG.
I'm gonna give you
$250,000 for 30%,
contingent on me taking it to a
protein and supplement company.
That's a yes, Daymond.
that's a yes.
all right.
Let's see
how they're doing now.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had $165,000 in sales.
Since airing a year ago,
we have $1.5 million in sales
and growing.
We now have
a fulfillment warehouse.
We've completely reformulated
and repackaged our product,
and we have created
over 30 new jobs.
After making my deal
with Daymond,
he introduced us to Kevin
from rightway nutrition,
who is a big player
in beverage manufacturing.
And he helped me
launch my product
into the mainstream market.
We are now on sale
at every Walgreens nationwide.
Over the next year,
we're projecting
over $3 million in sales.
Brandon Jacobs has been
instrumental to our company.
He's constantly pushing
our product to his friends,
his teammates, his fans --
anybody who will listen.
Yo, Brandon, what's up?
We're on the field here today
because we're gonna talk
to Brandon Jacobs about
our new national campaign.
We need to make people aware
that it's not only for athletes.
It's for everyday moms
and kids.
And with the new
developed flavors
and the way that they're
improved, kids actually like it.
This thing is bigger
than we thought.
Man, you've been a great
partner. Let's keep rocking.
Now why don't you show me some
football? Show us some moves.
PATRUNO: "Shark Tank" instantly
put us in the spotlight
and has given us every tool
to succeed.
I'm so thankful
for this experience
because it has completely
changed my life.
NARRATOR: Next up is an
entrepreneur from Austin, Texas,
with a new way to work out
while having fun.
JONES: Hello, sharks.
My name is Terry Jones,
and I'm the C.E.O. Of Nexersys.
We're seeking
a $2-million investment
for a 10% stake in our company.
Nexersys, the next-generation
exercise system,
is an interactive
and intelligent
fitness and gaming platform
that delivers a fast, fun, and
effective workout for everyone.
It doesn't matter
if you're an average Joe
or if you're
an Olympic medalist,
like my friend marlen esparza.
Nexersys combines the benefits
of a personal trainer
with the fun and excitement
of today's online games.
You simply select
your personal profile,
then you choose
between circuit training,
high-intensity interval rounds,
or a one-on-one challenge
against one
of our Nexersys avatars.
And you're ready to go.
[ bell dings ]
She would kick my ass.
There you go.
and when you're complete,
Nexersys provides
a detailed analysis of your work
every time you train.
You're gonna live a happier,
sexier, healthier life
using the same methods
as professional boxers
and MMA athletes
around the globe.
So, which of you sharks
would like to draw first blood
against your ultimate opponent?
We've got a, uh, special avatar
that we brought.
Hey!
GREINER: [ laughs ]
now, that's
a good-looking dude.
Go for it, Mark.
Be really easy on him.
he's a wonderful guy.
One-punch Cuban.
Where it lights up,
you hit.
JONES: Look at him.
CUBAN:
pop. I'm just gonna...
ah!
[ laughter ]
Mr. Wonderful,
you're in trouble.
I got to tell you.
[ laughs ]
oh!
[ bell dings ]
look at that.
Great work! Yeah!
awesome, Mark!
Way to go, Mark!
But you can see
Mark was 36% accurate.
He was hitting real hard, but
not necessarily real accurate.
I just wanted
to knock his ass out.
Great job. I believe
he knocked him out.
I didn't feel a thing.
Mark, was it fun?
It was a nice little workout.
how long did we do?
You did 15 seconds.
I mean, doing three minutes on
that would be a great workout.
O'LEARY: Eventually,
we got to get to this.
You put a huge valuation
on this company -- $20 million.
Do you have any sales?
Uh, we do. We are --
sales to date
are a little over $4 million.
Wow.
$4.2 million.
That's over about 18 months.
Do you make any money?
We are not profitable yet.
We should be profitable
in September of this year.
And is this designed
for gyms and the home?
Absolutely. The black model
is the personal model.
The silver model
is the commercial model.
Where are the sales?
give me the breakdown.
Currently, about 70% commercial
and about 30% home.
I think it's very cool.
I do really like it.
Well, you get demonstration,
I think, better
than almost anyone in the world
having your experience on QVC.
While you're groveling
up to Lori, let's go
back to the numbers.
What's your cost to make
one of those units?
Uh, just under $2,000
for the commercial unit.
Now, Terry, this is really
a digital punching bag.
A punching bag costs
about $1,200 --
a good one, leather,
et cetera.
What does that cost?
Uh, the commercial unit
is $7,000.
Whoa!
And it is --
no, that's cheaper...
So I can buy a car
or buy this.
[ laughs ]
Or you can buy a --
buy a treadmill
or an elliptical
in the same price range.
What about the home unit?
how much is that, Terry?
Uh, $2,995.
JOHN:
how do you sell them?
We sell --
we promote it on TV
with direct-to-consumer
advertising.
We sell it electronically.
So you've been
running infomercials?
We've run
one- and two-minute spots.
Not the long form, but, yes.
all right.
And how are those doing?
They did very well.
we ran them last year.
We spent about $1 million
in TV last year.
It generated about $1.5 million
in sales.
That brings up
something else.
How much in debt
are you?
Uh, we have
on our balance sheet
about $7.5 million
of shareholder debt.
Whoa!
I knew I was gonna
get to this after that one.
Whoa! Terry, Terry, Terry.
And how much of that
is your own money?
Uh... [ stammers ]
a small portion of that
is mine and my family's money.
And that means that now
we're gonna find out
you own very little
of this company, correct?
Um, I own about 35%
of the company.
You know, I'm a nice guy,
so I wouldn't do this to you.
But if I were
an opportunistic guy,
I would just simply wait
for that debt to come due,
and then I'd own
your company.
Basically, that's what
those debtors are gonna do.
If you don't figure out
a way to pay them,
they'll own all the equity
when this is over.
Uh, we don't believe
that's gonna happen
given where we are
in run rate.
By the time that debt is due,
our cash flow will allow us
to repay that debt.
But, you know, in life and
in business, poo-poo happens.
Don't you think
a savvy financial investor,
of which I'm gonna
include myself right now,
would want to see
that resolved
before I put a dime
into this company?
Because if I buy your equity at
this valuation of $20 million
and the debt guys
aren't happy,
I'm screwed, Terry.
We will be repaying that
and addressing that.
What happens
if you don't?
Well, we'll have to deal with
those creditors at that time.
TISCH: How many investors
do you have?
We have
about 60 investors.
60.
oh.
Have your investors
seen any money back yet?
Oh, hell, no.
No.
This is a story
about a lot of debt.
Great product.
too much debt.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I have gone to the future
in a split second,
and here's
what happened --
the debt wasn't paid back,
and those shareholders
wiped you out.
You are now an employee of the
company with no equity at all.
The smartest guys on the balance
sheet are always the debt guys.
They know your future
already.
Luckily, those guys
are also my common-stock
and convertible-to-venture
partners.
Yeah, but they're gonna own
a lot more than common.
No, that doesn't matter.
that doesn't mater.
They're gonna force you
into bankruptcy,
and anything that you own
is going to be gone.
Any assets that you had
are going to be sold.
And they're gonna take
their pennies on the dollar.
They're not your friend.
Good luck to you,
but I have a feeling
when we meet you again,
you're gonna be an employee.
That's it.
I'm out.
You know, I'd love to, uh, be
before you today with less debt.
Unfortunately,
the markets told us
how we could raise money
to deliver.
We're standing before you
with two products
with a $20-million valuation,
which is a fraction of companies
like total gym,
like nordictrack, like bowflex.
These are billion-dollar
market-cap companies that --
and you're not anything
like them at all.
Those are
very simple devices.
How you even spent $7.5 million
to develop this is beyond me.
And the valuation --
normally I'm the one
who doesn't care
about valuation
'cause you can always
grow past it.
Now you've learned
from the wise one.
I wouldn't call you the wise
one. But it's just crazy.
For that reason, I'm out.
You know, you're, like,
in the third round
with a young Mike Tyson.
He's given you two body blows,
but he's about to cock back
and crack your head
to the white meat.
[ laughter ]
That debt is dangerous.
I'm out.
And then there was one.
I like it. I think it looks
like a lot of fun.
Great way
to have a workout.
I think that
it's a great product.
You are in serious debt, but
I think you'll get out of it.
But I don't like to get
into that type of situation.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
thank you, sharks.
Good luck, Terry.
Thank you very much.
all the best.
JOHN: I don't know
if he's gonna get out, Lori.
His mouthpiece
is in the third row by now.
It's one of those slow-motion
"aaaaaaah!"
while I appreciate
what the sharks said,
I have no doubt that Nexersys
and our team will be successful.
We will overcome these
little balance-sheet issues
and continue to grow
to a profitable
and worldwide company.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
with a product to help capture
the world in a whole new way.
Hello, sharks.
my name is Bruno Francois.
My product is Cycloramic.
And today I'm seeking $90,000
in exchange
for 5% of my company.
Cycloramic is a smartphone app
that takes 360-degree
panoramic photo hands-free.
And you don't even need
a tripod.
With Cycloramic,
you're gonna be able
to truly capture
the whole picture.
I'm gonna show you
a short demonstration,
show you how amazing
Cycloramic is.
There you go.
[ camera shutter clicks ]
It took all the shots,
and it's gonna stitch
all the pictures together.
And here it is
in Cycloramic's 3-D viewer.
So, the base that that's on --
do you need that base with it?
No, no, it works on the glass
or granite countertop.
No, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
how does it spin?
Not the wood.
the base that's spinning it.
No, no,
the base doesn't spin.
It's the phone that spins.
How does the phone spin?
How does it do it?
can we see it move?
H-how do you get an iPhone
to spin?
Can we see it move
without the base?
Yeah, yeah, of course.
here.
So, you see, it's gonna turn
and do a 180.
GREINER:
and it doesn't fall over.
[ camera shutter clicks ]
no, no, it doesn't.
O'LEARY: Cool.
[ camera shutter clicks ]
JOHN: Wow!
I want to buy that.
What is in the app that makes
the phone move on its own?
So, what we did is when we saw
that it was moving a little bit,
like, with the vibration,
we play with the frequency,
which we, like,
turn it on and off.
And then we tried the rotation
with the gyro and the compass,
and we see how fast it goes
and we adjust.
So if it gets stuck,
we kind of go on and off.
And we're able to do a whole 360
and then film or take pictures.
So, to be clear,
the app uses the phone's
own vibration
to make it spin.
There's no extra accessory,
nothing else.
There's no extra.
no extra.
Do you have a patent
on it?
yes, I do have a patent.
Utility patent.
yes.
Very interesting.
TISCH: Okay, so,
how are you selling this?
On iTunes.
on the app store.
How much are you charging
for it?
Right now it's 99 cents.
And how -- how much
have you sold?
Total downloads --
around 660,000.
What were your sales with
that number of downloads?
Income is $175,000.
And what are you projecting
in sales for this fiscal year?
Well, I'm hoping to do
$1 million this year.
We got like 300,000 views
in like a couple of days.
Can I ask you
about the valuation?
So you want $90,000 for 5%,
which puts you at $1.8 million.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Why are you valuing it
at $1.8 million?
Since it's a startup that
has never got any investment,
it's difficult to put, like,
a really precise value.
And there's nothing else
that you see out there like it
on the market today?
No, nobody.
nobody has done it. Nobody.
So, here's the thing --
I love your ingenuity.
Thank you.
and I love this.
You know, I can say --
I can tell instantly
if it's a hero or a zero.
I think
this is a megawatt hero.
It's a hero.
I'm sorry to interrupt
the love fest.
well, I...
Are you gonna make an offer
or not?
I am going to
offer you...
$200,000 for 10%.
FRANCOIS: Okay.
I'm an inventor, too.
And I know what it's like to
be you and stand in your shoes.
I get that excitement
and that fever,
and I will work with you
at lightning speed
to get this out there
everywhere.
I think
it's a very good offer.
You may want to know, as well,
I do have prototype for a base
that will rotate, you know.
And I do have
a provisional patent on that.
So hardware.
on a base that turns.
FRANCOIS: For any phone.
for any phone.
So you can put any phone,
and it rotate.
Bruno, you know, I have
an offer on the table.
Yeah, I apologize.
Are you interested
to hear any other offers?
I know that -- that --
or you just want to listen
to her squawk?
I really like your offer.
Do you mind if I listen
to everybody?
You know, just out of respect,
if they want to talk
and ask more questions?
I don't think
I want to sit here
waiting for them to figure out
what they want to do.
So I'd like you
to tell me right now
if you're going to take my offer
or not.
CUBAN: That would
be a mistake.
JOHN: She's very rude.
That would be
a mistake.
she's very rude.
You wouldn't want to do it
with somebody like that.
They think it may be a mistake,
but I'm sitting here saying...
Maybe she's not
the right partner at all.
That's the real issue
for you.
...You've got a bird
in the hand.
Maybe you should take it.
I respect Lori's hustle,
right?
But there's obvious outlets
for this that may not be obvious
to someone who
doesn't understand
the technology, right?
These are apps that I have to
deal with every day.
I'm an investor in a company
called condition one.
They do panoramic video.
I have a company called
motionloft that is being used
by the commercial
real-estate companies
that tracks people
as they walk by
so they can count
in real time.
Mark, it sounds like
you're selling him on you.
Exactly.
so are you going to
make him an offer?
Well, I want to hear more.
I want to hear more about
what the road map is.
The application is great.
it's interesting.
But your upside, really, is
to sell it to Instagram or vine
'cause they have
the user base,
and this is a huge add-on
for them.
But the exciting thing
is since you've been able
to capture the use
of the vibrations,
where else can you take it
in terms of applications?
Because that's where
the world opens up for you
in terms
of product development.
Well, there's one big
application -- is games.
I've got a company
called mention mobile.
that's all they do.
JOHN:
I think I've heard enough.
I will offer you $250,000
for 10%.
Okay.
So now you have to
ask yourself,
"how much equity
do I have to give up?"
the challenge
with the app market --
I've invested in lots of apps
and tech companies --
is you're an app
right now.
You're not
a company yet.
And so you've got to run
this app as far as you can,
extract as much cash
as you can --
CUBAN: That's absolutely
not true.
You're getting 77 cents from it
right now.
That's absolutely not true,
and he knows it.
That's absolutely true
because the only --
it shows how little
he understands the technology.
Let me finish talking,
Mark.
I appreciate your input, but
it's not useful to me right now.
You're welcome.
so I don't want to hear it.
So at the end of the day,
if you can build
a portfolio of technologies,
then you might be able
to sell your company
a couple of years
from now.
So why give up any equity
until you've had a chance
to build this out
a little bit?
Oh, my God. Here comes
the licensing-royalty joke.
Exactly is what you need.
[ laughs ]
you don't want to be
the punch line.
Here's the deal.
I'll give you your 90k.
FRANCOIS: Mm-hmm.
I'll take a 15% royalty
only on the revenues
of this application.
Okay.
I'm the only shark up here
that actually made a living
as a photographer.
Okay.
and I think that this --
When was that?
How did that
work out for you?
It went very well,
thank you.
So I was a professional
photographer and cinematographer
and an editor for years.
FRANCOIS: Okay.
That's why you and I have
a commonality here.
You have three offers
on the table.
Hold on. Lori, do you want me
as your partner in this?
Will you let me
come in with you?
He may sweeten the pot.
O'LEARY: Interesting.
I'm gonna offer Bruno
$250,000 for 10%.
Now...
half mine, half yours.
JOHN:
you're equaling my offer?
I'm equaling your offer, but
Lori and I will be partners.
If that's a value
to Bruno,
I think it's a better offer,
okay?
He's got a lot
of connections.
FRANCOIS: Yes.
O'LEARY:
You basically have two offers
for $250,000
for 10% of the equity.
If you don't want
to give up any equity,
I'm happy to partner with you
and do all of the things
you want to do.
I have a question
about licensing.
Do you think
there would be any way
to license the technology
to the manufacturer?
If you want to license
this technology
the hardware guys
bundled with this app,
that's not a problem,
either.
I'm the king of licensing.
GREINER: Let's stop.
TISCH: Bruno, do you want
two real partners?
Close your eyes,
stop for a minute,
and think to yourself,
"what do I really want?
what feels right?"
breathe.
Are you done playing games
with these guys, Bruno?
I'm gonna offer you
$1 million...
Oh.
...For 30%.
That's more than
a $3-million valuation.
It's a sweet deal!
NARRATOR: Bruno has four offers
on the table --
$250,000 for 10%
from Lori and Steve...
$90,000 for a 15% royalty
and zero equity from Kevin...
$250,000 for 10% from Daymond...
And $1 million for 30%
from Mark.
The only deal that really
makes sense is mine...
of course.
...Where you don't give up
any of your equity.
I'll go -- I'll go
to $300,000 for 10%.
Um...
GREINER: And what partner
do you really want?
TISCH: Yeah, what partner
or partners?
I bring sports business,
entertainment business.
I think your product has
applications in both industries.
Lori, obviously --
CUBAN: Ask them to explain
how the product works.
See if they understand it.
As he's making decisions
in what direction to go
with the product,
if you don't understand
how software's written,
how are you gonna offer
any guidance, right?
O'LEARY: I'm gonna make it
more interesting for you.
I'll give you $200,000 for 10%,
but when you pay me back,
I lose 5% of my equity.
So you get back
to what you wanted.
You earn it back because
we're gonna run like hell
to sell as many of these
as we can.
TISCH: Bruno, Lori and I will
make the same offer as Kevin.
And $50,000 more.
$250,000, 10%.
pay us back, it's down to 5%.
I will offer you $350,000
for 12%.
Okay.
Do you understand
all the offers now?
yeah, yeah.
I do have a question
for Mark.
How would you feel
working with Lori, as well?
Okay.
I'm not opposed to it.
So, how much of that
would you want?
50/50.
You're okay with putting up
$500,000?
So you just threw Steve
under a bus.
okay.
Yeah. Lori just
kicked me to the curb.
Welcome to the Shark Tank,
rook!
JOHN: She just ignores her
other partner like that.
Oh, don't listen to them.
do you see that?
TISCH: Absolutely.
horrible.
Don't listen to them.
Kevin...
Why don't you and Daymond
invite me into your deal?
Interesting.
GREINER: Mark, we need
to close our deal now.
They're shuffling deck chairs
on the Titanic.
This is not deck chairs
There is not an iceberg
in sight.
Bruno, do not give up
your equity.
I want to be able to decrease
a little bit of the equity
for future investment.
yeah.
But, you know,
I don't want you to lower
the percent for nothing,
so I'm giving something back.
CUBAN: How much money would you
want out of that $1 million?
I wouldn't want to give away
that much equity,
so probably $500,000
would be...
Okay.
so $500,000 for 16.5%.
So each of us would have
8.25% for 250k.
It's a good deal.
let's do it.
Come on. Close it.
I think a better deal
is I like my --
do you want to hear
another offer...
wait.
...Where you give up
less equity?
Stop. Stop.
because...
We were
just about to close.
No, you weren't.
JOHN: No, you weren't.
Sit down, Lori.
But can you
just come down?
I mean, I'm really close
to making a deal,
but 15% seems like...
TISCH: Bruno,
we've got a...
So at 15% -- Lori...
Yeah?
...It's not worth
nickel and diming.
So 15%, $500,000?
yes.
And you know
we're the right partners.
Yes or no. Got to go.
You gave up 5%
for nothing.
Kevin.
Bruno, you got to
make up your mind.
You've got a deal.
Deal. Yeah.
yay!
Awesome. [ laughs ]
it's gonna be great.
Congratulations.
all right, thank you.
Looking forward to it.
all right.
Congratulations, though.
TISCH: Bruno,
congratulations.
Thank you very much.
GREINER: Thank you.
Thanks, Bruno.
all right.
FRANCOIS: 15% is a little more
than what I came for,
but I got a higher valuation,
and you know, Lori, for
inventions for me, is important.
And then Mark Cuban, you know,
for all the startups
he's involved
and all the connections,
it's a great value.
I think --
I wanted to get two sharks.
I didn't want just one.
That was awesome, Mark.
No, it wasn't.
yes, it was.
You're just
a sore loser.
All I'm saying is our deal
would have been much better
for him.
He'll probably sleep on it
and start crying.
[ laughs ] Oh, God.